je m'appelle paul j'ai 34 ans et je suis
séropositive depuis 2009 donc depuis que
j'ai 22 ans chris pine 52 ans contaminée
par le vih en 1990 j'en ai dit qu'à man
c'est ça c'est une petite pilule je
prends avec un verre d'eau pour le vih
j'ai un médicament
en revanche pour les pathologies
associées au vih telles que la
transplantation hypertension j'ai une
douzaine de médicaments par jour
[Musique]
quand j'ai appris ma séropositivité j'ai
une phase où je me suis laissée car même
en mourir où je mangeais plus enfin
voilà une île football fini la vie
familiale d'avoir des enfants etc
pour moi c'était c'était plus
d'actualité donc j'allais mourir et
c'était vraiment l'issue qui qui
m'attendait je vais accepter de
participer à un essai concorde qui était
l'arrivée du premier médicament
l'adapter sur le sur le marché et qui
faisait que peut-être on aurait un
traitement donc malheureusement il a eu
des effets secondaires importants sur un
sur sur moi avec une neuropathie donc
j'ai dû arrêter et puis en 97 les
première trithérapie qui sont arrivés et
là c'était un ouf de soulagement
maladie de la griffe du chat après j'ai
d'autres trucs sympas ils trouvaient pas
j'ai subi une transformation de mon
corps qui sait masculiniser j'avais un
déplacement des graisses qui s'était
opéré dans les dents les bras et danger
de l'être se subir une liposuccion qui
fait qu'on a enlevé retirer un livre de
graisse sur les deux bras donc voilà ça
fait partie du quotidien mais c'est ça
aussi le vivre avec
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le vih c'est juste un virus
qui est dans votre corps et qui est
maîtrisé et donc comme il est maîtrisé
il n'y a pas de déclenchement de
maladies
donc je peux répondre tout mon sens dans
la rue on peut aller se rouler dedans on
va pas attraper le vih
j'ai pas de vias dans le sens j'ai pas
de voyage dans les spurs
[Musique]
sur les appliquer comme grinder par
exemple c est ce que tu es clean est ce
que tu es clean ça veut dire en anglais
c'est dire est ce que tes propres
ben spies étudier avec le vih que tes
sales en fait
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de rester dans le milieu et
puis de continuer à vivre l'énergie
positive qui est celle du sport aussi et
ses valeurs et parce que quand on est
bien dans sa tête on est bien dans son
corps et moi c'est vraiment mon
leitmotiv chaque jour
[Musique]